Corie asks what's the best way to grow a
following or a community from nothing
Cory this is easy for me to answer since
I've done it a couple of times and and
the real answer is content and context
my belief is the best way to build a
following right now is to put out daily
if you can content and get as close to
that as possible right and so every day
put out your picture or your drawing on
your snapchat that you blast out or your
Instagram photos or your video show or
whatever you may be doing your written
blog every day you know six days is
better than five days and five days is
better than four days and four days is
better than three days in two days is
better than one day a week but if you're
doing it one or two or three days a week
are you really doing it
so pumping out hardcore content and then
engaging I'm going to ask a question of
the day today and hopefully after I get
home at 11:30 12:00 tonight I'm going to
go into the comments and reply to some
of those answers creating context you've
empowered me by watching my show I then
jumped back in to answer your question
of the day answer showing you that I
appreciate you we've created a deeper
context just like what I reply to you or
answer your email or some of the cyber
dusts I've done the last 24 hours
it's about content and context building
community takes work building community
is not a foregone conclusion everybody
just thinks you're going to start a show
and everything's going to magically
happen or you start a blog and you can
already become an Instagram sensation
the talent to put out the content is
only one piece of the equation one
percent of the magic one percent get it
just by the content push out but for the
rest of us chaps and Chipettes we've got
to put in the work into the community
and care back to the time they've
allocated the fact that people are
spending ten minutes to watch this in
your ridiculously busy world is
something I will never ever take for
granted